Here we are on problem
number 8.
The total daily profit, p in
dollars, from producing and
selling x units of a certain
product is given by the
function p of x.
So the profit as a function of
x is equal to 17x minus 10x
plus b where b is a constant.
If 300 units were produced and
sold yesterday for a profit of
$1,900, what is the
value of b?
So we know that p of 300-- 300
units-- the profit when we did
300 units is $1,900.
And we want to figure out b.
So what is p of 300?
So let's put 300 in here.
We know it also equals 1,900
but let's put it here.
So it's 17 times 300 minus
10 times 300 plus b.
I just put 300 in for x.
So we're trying to find the
profit for 300 and we know
already that equals 1,900.
So what's 17 times 300?
17 times 3 is 51.
Let's add those two 0s.
Minus-- and what's 10 times 300,
that's 3,000-- 3,000 plus
b is equal to 1,900.
And then we get 5,100
minus 3,000 minus
b is equal to 1,900.
What's 5,100 minus 3,000?
2,100.
And 2,100 minus b is
equal to 1,900.
Minus b is equal to, subtract
2,100 from both sides, and you
get minus 200.
b is equal to 200.
And that is choice E.
Next problem.
Problem number 9.
I will switch colors.
The number that results when
an integer is multiplied by
itself cannot end in which
of the following digits?
Interesting.
Well, what's a number when it's
multiplied by itself?
That's like squaring a number.
So let's kind of study
what all the perfect
squares look like.
So when I square 1, I get 1.
When I square 2 I get 4.
When I square 3 I get 9.
Square 4 I get 16.
5 is 25.
6 is 36.
7 is 49.
8 is 64.
So let's look at the numbers
that it can be.
OK, we could go 9 is 81.
Looks like it can be a 1, a
4, a 9-- and we could keep
going-- 1, 4, 9, a 6, a 5, and
actually if we went to, 8 is
64 so it's a 4.
9 is-- oh we already
did that-- and
then 10 is a 0, right?
It can also end in a 0.
The choices, A, sure a
number can end in 1.
We just figured that out.
Choice B, sure a number
can end in 4.
Choice C, sure a number
can end in 5.
Thus 25 as an example.
Choice D, a number
can end in 6.
Choice E, well none of
the numbers we looked
at end in an 8.
And it seems like there's a bit
of a pattern here, that it
tends to be just a set-- a
subset-- of these numbers.
And also we know that the other
choices-- choices A
through D-- we can figure out
perfect squares that end in
those numbers.
So we know that the
answer is E.
Next problem.
Problem number 10.
A bag contains only red marbles,
blue marbles, and
yellow marbles.
The probability of randomly
selecting a red marble from
this bag is 1/4.
So I can say the probability
of red is equal to 1/4.
The probability of randomly
selecting a
blue marble is 1/6.
Which of the following could be
the total number of marbles
in the bag?
Fascinating.
So what we need to do is we need
to essentially figure out
the ratio of red to blue
to yellow marbles.
So first of all, what's the
probability of getting a
yellow marble?
The probability of getting a
yellow marble is going to be 1
minus these, right?
So probability of yellow
is going to be 1
minus 1/6 minus 1/4.
Let's see, we could put
all of that over 12.
12 minus 2/6 minus 3/12--
3/12 is 1/4.
So that equals-- what's
12 minus 10?
That equals 7/12.
So the probability I get a
yellow marble is 7/12.
So that means for every 7
marbles-- so let's write it
all is a denominator of 12.
That makes it actually
a lot easier.
1/6 is the same thing as 2/12.
And 1/4 is the same
thing as 3/12.
And they all add up to 12/12.
So for every 3 red marbles,
there are 2 blue marbles and
there are 7 yellow marbles.
The ratio of red to blue to
yellow is equal to 3:2:7.
And we know we can only get
this type of a ratio when
there's a total of 12
marbles, right?
There has to be at least 12
marbles or any multiple of 12
marbles, right?
If there's exactly 2 blue
marbles, then there'll be 3
red and 7 yellow.
And there has to be at least
2 of the blue marbles.
So any multiple of 12 marbles
will work for
this type of ratio.
So if we look at the choices,
which of the following could
be the total number of
marbles in the bag?
So out of all those choices,
which of them are
a multiple of 12?
Well, choice A isn't.
10 isn't a multiple of 12.
Choice C isn't.
18, 20, 30.
Well 12 is a multiple of 12,
so choice B is our answer.
And we just figured out.
If there were 3 red, 2 blue and
7 yellow, then we get the
correct probabilities.
The key is just to try to
figure out what the
probability of getting a yellow
is and then realizing
the ratios between the two.
Next problem.
Problem 11.
When the sum of a list of
prices is divided by the
average of the prices
the result is k.
What does k represent?
So if I take the sum divided
by the average.
So let's say I'm taking the
sum of three numbers.
So let's say, n1 plus
n2 plus n3.
I could do it n times, but
just for simplicity.
And I'm dividing that
by the average.
What's the average?
It's n1 plus n2 plus n3
divided by 3, right?
And if you divide by a fraction,
that's the same
thing as multiplying
by the reciprocal.
So that's n1 plus n2 plus
n3 times 3 over n1
plus n2 plus n3.
So this cancels out, and all
we're left with is 3, which is
the number of numbers we had.
And you could have done this
with 16 or 20 or whatever.
I mean you could have
said n1 plus n2 plus
da, da, da, da, da.
Where I have, let's say, n
sub-- let's say I have m
digits-- and then divide that by
n1 plus n2 plus blah, blah,
blah, blah.
n over m.
Sub m digits.
And say, well I'm
dividing by m.
This would have also simplified
to m digits.
When you do what they said in
the problem, the result is
just the number of prices
that you are summing.
So that is choice D, the
number of prices.
And it works out because
this sum and this
sum will cancel out.
Next problem.
Let's see how fast-- if
I can fit this one in.
So I have a drawing.
It looks like this.
Let's see, triangle, triangle,
triangle, triangle, and then
dotted lines, dotted lines,
dotted lines, dotted lines.
It says, if the area of the
square in the figure above is
81-- so they're saying this is
a square, and if the area is
81-- then we know that this side
is 9 and this side is 9.
Right?
This is 9 times 9.
And the perimeter of each of
the four triangles is 30.
So the perimeter is 30
of each of those.
What is the perimeter of
the figure outlined
by the solid line?
Well think about it.
The perimeter of the solid
line, that would be this.
That's what we want
to figure out.
Well wouldn't that just be
the perimeter of the four
triangles, and then we want to
subtract out this side, this
side, this side and
this side, right?
The perimeter of the red part
is the perimeter of each of
the triangles-- added up, all
four of them-- minus the
perimeter of the
square inside.
So the perimeter of the four
triangles is 30 times 4, minus
the perimeter of this,
which is minus 27.
No whoops, minus 36.
So it's 120 minus
36 and that is--